宜しくお願いします
では
我々が亡くなったら
死にましたら
どうなるのでしょうか？
というテーマだそうですけど
私もあまりこのテーマを
それほど気にはしなかったのですけど
12時頃になってしまったら
どうしようとか
思ってしまったのですけど
実は 死にましたら
どうなりますかと
分かりません
分かりませんから
それだけのことなのです 話は...
鈴木さんはやっぱり
来世 再生というのはあるかないか
ということについて
理論的な 色々な概念を
いくつか取り上げましたけど
それはもしかすると
私に対する注意かもしれません
そんなことをしゃべるなと
だから
それも困ってしまったし
その場合はテーマは違いますけど
本当に 実際人間に
来世はあるかないかという
テーマになりますから
今日 私のテーマは
人は亡くなったら
どうなるのですかと
答えは
全然分かりません
それは 頭にまず
置いておいて下さい
それで世の中には
いろんな宗教がございまして
亡くなったら それで
パーになってしまいますと
それで全部終わりますと
虚無ですと
何にもないという
宗教は一つもないのです
不思議なことは
我々は死にましたらどうなるか
分からないのに
良くその人々は分かっているのですね
と僕は聞きたいのです
仏教といっても いろんな宗派が
いっぱいありまして
どんな宗派の話を聞いても
一応現代の たまにお坊さんたちが
いらっしゃいまして
「やっぱり来世はないのです」と
言っているお坊さんたちもいますけど
だいたいどんな宗派にしても
私たちの上座部仏教にしても
日本のいろんな大乗仏教の
各宗派にしても
やっぱり 死んでしまったら
何とかなりますと思っているし
言っているし
仏教以外に 他の宗教
ヒンドゥー教やらキリスト教やら
他の宗教の話を見ると
みんな 死後の世界を
延々としゃべっているのです
そこで 私は聞きたいのは
本当にあなた方は
分かっているのですかと
私も分からないのにと
良く分かっているように
お話はしているのです
そこで 私は考えるのは
こういうことなのです
人間がやっぱり死んでしまったら
それで全部終わってしまったと
全部パーになったと
チャラになったと
信じたくはないのです
そうでしょう？
皆さんもそうだと思います
で もし私が仮にそう言ったならば
全部パーですと
何もないのだと
死んでしまったら
こう言われたら困りますと
お寺はどうするのですかと
そういう風な話になるのです
それはお寺の運営のことを
困っているだけではないかと
それで 鈴木さんもおっしゃったように
では修行はどうですかとか
どんな意味がありますかとか
そういう問題は取り出します
でも だからといって
死んでしまったらどうなるか
分かっているものではないのです
とりあえず こういう風に
考えてみましょう
私たちはやっぱり死んで
それで終わりたくないのです
だから それはみんな
分かっているのです
いろんな宗教を教えている人々も
人間は死にましたら
それで終わりますとは
終わりたいとは思っていないこと
だけは分かっているのです
それでいろいろ教義を作って
我々のこの切ない願いを
何とか慰めてくれる
良い子にしていれば
良い子 良い子だと
実際にその問題に対し本気になって
疑ってかかったことはないのです
ですから 今日も本当は私はもう
いろんなことを話したいのですが
いろんな訳があって なかなか
しゃべれない状況もありますけど
例えば ヨーロッパ的な
キリスト教的な考え方を
取り上げてみると
神様さえ信じておけば
亡くなった人々はみんな
天国という特別な場所に
連れて行かれるのだと
そこですべての物は揃っていて
もう二度と死なないし
大変楽しく楽に生活できるのだと
神様を信じてなかったら
その人々はみんな
地獄に落ちてしまうのだと
落ちて 永遠の苦しみを
永遠に味わっているのだと
そういう風に言うと
我々はやっぱり
死んでも 死にたくないし
やっぱり しょうがなく
神様のことを信じて
そこら辺 永遠の喜びを味わうために
頑張らなくてはいけないのです
そういう風になってしまうのです
そこで問題は イスラム教の
人々から話を聞くと
アッラーという神様が
いらっしゃいまして
その神様以外誰一人も信じたならば
絶対許さないのだそうです
唯一の神以外
何者も信仰したら
絶対にそれは許す訳には
いきませんし
地獄に落ちてしまうし
そのポイントから見れば
日本人みんな
地獄に落ちるのです
いくら頑張ってももうダメです
なぜかというとイスラム教徒の
日本の方々もいますけど
やっぱり日本人の
悪い癖 良い癖か分かりませんけど
イスラム教から見れば
大変悪い癖があるのです
どこら辺でも神社があったら
すぐそこに頭を下げてしまうし
とても美しい
樹齢を重ねている大きな木
大木（たいぼく）ですか
そういうのを見たら
「ああ 神木だ」と言って
それにまた礼をするし
分かりやすく よく見ることは
日の出ですか 朝
美しい空で
太陽が出てくると
合掌して礼をしない日本人が
一人もいないのです
そんなことはアッラーの神様の
腹が立ちます
そんなことをしてしまったら
だから地獄に落ちたくなければ
それらは全部やめなくては
ならないのです
だから今から覚悟しておいた方が
良いのです 我々は
我々と言っても 私は違いますけど
日本人は 日本の皆様方はやっぱり
そういう何となく美しいもの
自然の堂々たるもの
山とか
そういうものはやっぱり
心から感謝するか
礼をするかという
習慣がありまして
それは良いことかも知れませんが
残念ながら
イスラム教徒の人々から見れば
地獄に落ちてしまうのです
だいたいこの大胆な
宗教的に言えば
このヨーロッパ的な宗教だけ
なのですが
東洋の世界にある宗教は
そんなに過激に大胆なことは
言いませんから
いくらかのんびりすることは
できるのです
例えば 仏様を信じなかったら
地獄に落ちますと
あるいは 阿弥陀様を
きちんと念仏しなかったら
必ず地獄に落ちます
とは言わないのです
そこら辺で少々
優しいところはありますけど
それが分からないのは
あれもちょっとした
慰めかどうか分からないのです
そういうのは分からないのだけど
だから 実際どういうものでしょうか
死んでしまったら
どうなるのでしょうか？
それは
初めから言っているように
分からないのです
ですから これを試す方法が
一つあるのです
たった一つだけ
自分で死んでみるのです
死んでみて 私たちに教えて下さい
それもちょっとした
欠点がありまして
死ぬ方々はいっぱいいるのですが
一人も教えてくれないのです
「死ぬということはどういうことか」と
一人も教えてくれないのに我々は
いくらか信じてはいるのです
死後の何かあるのだろうと
なぜこういう話をしたかというと
「長部経典」という
パーリ聖典の中の経典がありまして
その中に一つのお経があります
そのお経の中で
その人は「唯物論」
そのお経の中に出る人が
いわゆる「物質」しか
何もこの魂や あるいはこころやら
アートマンやら
そんなものは何も存在しないのだと
霊魂やらそんなものは下らない話だと
ただ身体があることは確かですと
かなりの唯物論者なのです
その人は ある日
あるお坊さんを見たのです
一生懸命托鉢している
お坊さんを見たのです
見たら「では からかってやろう」と
お坊さんは托鉢に行くのだから
一応この人は金持ちで
政治家で いわゆる王家の人
「王様」とは言っていないのだけど
「王子」ですか "Prince"
という名前で呼ばれていますけど
とにかくそのお坊さんを呼んだのです
自分のお城に
呼んで お食事の用意も
ちゃんとしてあげて
お互いに話し合っていたのです
話し合っていたら
この王子様が
この世の中でくだらない坊主たち
くだらない宗教家たちがいて
人は死んでしまったら
どこかに生まれ変わると
そんなくだらないことを
言っているのだと
本当は人が死んでしまったら
どこにも行けないのだ
それで終わりですと
この身体が地・水・火・風という
四つの物で作られていて
それはそれで自然に戻りますと
何を言っているのですかと
言ったら あのお坊さんも
私も
もう
こういう風なくだらないことは
聞いたことがないのだと
どういう風なくだらないことですかと
人が死んでしまったら ただ単に
簡単に地・水・火・風に戻りますと
それ以上何もないのだと
そんな馬鹿げた話は一度も
聞いたことがないのですと
王子様に当たったのです いきなり
そこで この王子様が
ある一部の地方を管理しているのだから
裁判を起こしたり
悪いことをした人を処刑にしたりとか
する権利があるのです
それで彼がこう言うのです
私の所で犯罪を犯した人が来たら
私はその人を死刑にするのだと
死刑にすると色々実験したのです
この人が とんでもない実験ですけど
一つはこの
打ち首ですか？がありますから
その人を処刑する所に行って
「では はい もう執行しなさい」
と言うのです
言って 剣で首を切るのです
切った瞬間で王様が
切った傷口をじっと見ていたのだと
「なぜ見ていたのですか？」と聞いたら
もうこの人は死んでしまったのだから
その人の霊魂やら魂やら
もしどこかで再生するならば
この身体から出て行くはずなのです
それで「出ていくかな？」
と見ていたのです
でも 見えない
「なるほど これは失敗だ」と
もう一つ実験したのです
もう一人の人がこういう風に
処刑になったところで
この人が量ってみたのです
体重はいくらあるのですかと
量ってみて
血一滴も流さないように
窒息させたかどうか分かりませんけど
その人を殺してしまったのです
殺すってその場合言うかどうか...
殺しは殺しですけど
いわゆる処刑に決めた人だから
殺したら血一滴も身体から
出て行っていないのです
それで死体を量ってみるのです
もし来世に何か行くならば
体重で分かりますと 重さで
結果はどうなったのですかというと
生きている時に量った体重と
死んでから量った体重を比べてみると
死んでから重いのです
「あ くだらない話だ」と
この王子様が思ったのです
なぜならば もし身体から何か
出て行ってどこかで再生するならば
死んだ遺体は
死んでから遺体は
軽くなるはずなのです
１mgでも軽くなるはずなのです
１mgでも軽くなるはずが
もう重くなってしまったのです
その中で実験はずっと並んでいますけど
あれはほとんど作り話かもしれませんし
この王子様が行った実験として
いろんな宗教で再生論を言っていますから
死後の話を言っていますから
何か間接的にこのお経で
そのお経を作ったのは
仏教の人々だから
仏教の人々は馬鹿にしているのです
一つは 我々に魂があるのだと
それは こころの中に
住んでいるのだという話であって
パンチャ・コーシャ・アートマンという
アートマンに 我に 魂に
身体が五つありますと言う話は
皆様も ヨーガの世界を
知っている皆様方は
聞いたことがあると思います
アートマンに
何と言いますか
鎧のような この
五つがあるのだと
外にあるものは それほど
徹底したアートマンではなくて
一番中に本物の真我があるのだと
五つの殻から覆われていて
その説もその王子様は
聞いていたのだから
ある人を処刑にする時は
その人を殺さないで
まず皮膚を全部
剥くというのですか
剥がしてみたのです
剥がして じっと見ていたのです
魂が抜けて行くのだと
まだ生きているのだから
それから
徐々に筋肉も
切ってみたのです
人が死んでしまうまで
全然アートマンというものは
霊魂は見つからなかったと
だから
あの人は最終的に
宗教で言っているのは
「死後の何か世界があります」と
「死後我々は何とかになるのだ」
というのは
それはもうはっきりとした
下らない話だと 嘘だと
決めてしまったのです
お経の最後の部分が
一番大事なのですけど
そこで仏教のお坊さんが
阿羅漢でしたけど
どう対応したのですかと
私もそんな話はそれほど
面白くないのだから
忘れてしまったのです
その最後の部分は
ですから 残念ながら
疑問の中で止まるしかないのです
皆様は
もしそれでも疑問で嫌だな
と思うならば
長部経典にそのお経が
入っているのです
注：長部経典第二部大篇
第23経パーヤーシ経
名前はそのうち思い出します
出てくるのは（※第二部）です
長部経典の
一部 二部 三部とありまして
で お釈迦様は
本当に死後の何か世界ありますかと
言ったのでしょうかと
ではその話に 私は一応
今日は本題として
入りたがっているのです
今日は 例えば
このお寺の系列の宗派では
極楽浄土という概念がありまして
他の宗派でも いろいろ
概念があるのです
そういう話をしている訳
ではないのです
それをテーラワーダ仏教
まとめて
各宗派仏教では もう一応前提として
「死後の世界はあります」と
決めつけて それから
「その世界はどんなものか」と
話しているのだから
それは置いておきましょう
それは死後の世界が
「あるならば」の話なのですから
死後何か「あるならば」の話なのです
それは極楽浄土ですか
あるいはキリスト教徒みたいに
天国ですかと
ですから 今日はそういう
我々仏教の仲間はそういう点で
喧嘩する必要はないのです
だいたいお釈迦様は そんなに大胆に
そんな問題は考えていないみたいです
ほとんど お経では
仮に何となく引用するだけであって
そんな これからあなた方に
死後の話をしましょうとか
そんな話はほとんど
していないのです
それより 我々はどう生きるべきかと
そればっかりなのです
99%
まあ「.9」も入れても良いのです
99.9%ぐらいの教えは
そこで 仏教はどんどん時代を経ると
出るわ出るわ 死後の世界の話は
ああなります こうなりますとか
初期時点ではそれほど引用していない
それも覚えておいて頂きたいのです
それより大事なのは
我々の生き方であると
死ぬまでどう生きたら良いのですか
ということは
一番大事なポイントなのです
そこで
APAṆṆAKA（アパンナカ）
という言葉がお経に出てくるのです
APAṆṆAKA
APAṆṆAKAという言葉
その名前のお経が一つあります
前に引用したのは 長部経典
今引用しているのは 中部経典
中部経典にはお経が153ありまして
長部経典には37ぐらいあります
結構長いのです
一つでも読み切れないほど
ですから
APAṆṆAKA Sutta
（アパンナカ・スッタ）
ともいうのです
APAṆṆAKA Sutta
APAṆṆAKAって
どういう意味ですかと
APAṆṆAKAっていうのは
英語で言えば
No question（ノー・クエスチョン）
という意味です
問題にならないのだと
という題なのです
いわゆる選択の余地がないと
というタイトルです
そこで中身はどういうことかというと
こういうことなのです
ある人々が
人は死にましたら
全く何もない
もう空（から）だと もう虚無だと
もうチャラだと
終わりだと言っているのだと
ある人々は「いえ 違います」と
「人が亡くなったら
それで輪廻転生しています」と
そう言っているのだと
そこで いろんな各宗教の人々は
お互いに喧嘩しているのだと
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
知識ある人にとっては
これはどっちでも良い
結構なことだと
分からないものだから
死んだらまた命がありますか
或いは死んだらまた命がないか
そんなものは分かったものでは
ないのだから どうでも良いのだと
それより こう訊くのです
例えば 人が
殺生するわ
盗みをするわ
邪な行為はやりたい放題やるわ
人に思う存分嘘をつくわ
悪口は言うわ
人を叱ったり けなしたりするわと
そこでありとあらゆる下らない
間違っている
社会の人間を害する 損をさせる
考え方を持っているわ
強烈な怒りは持っているわと
強烈な欲を持っているのだと
それは十悪です
皆様 だいたい仏教用語でいえば
お分かりになると思いますけど
一応僕は意味だけ言います
あまり覚えられないように
覚えてしまったら 困るのです
なぜならば「自分が知っている」
と思ってしまうのです
知っているということは
脳細胞が働かないのです
脳細胞が働かなかったら
何の意味もないのです
ですから できるだけ
覚えにくいようにしゃべるのです
用語をどんどん出してしゃべるのは
私にとってもしゃべりやすいし
時間もちゃんとコントロール
できますけど 秒単位で
できるだけやらないようにします
とにかく
ある人は そういう風に
十悪をしているのだと
殺生したり 盗みをしたり
邪な行為をしたり
嘘を言ったり 悪口を言ったり
無駄話を言ったり
噂をしたりとか
強烈な欲と強烈な怒りを持っていたり
それから大変な 危ない 危険な
いろんな哲学やら思想やら持っていて
それを世界中に言いふらしたりとか
やっているのだと
邪見です 用語で言えば
その人々は
例えば 来世がないと
どうなるのでしょうか？と
来世がないにしても その人々は
世の中でどう受け止めて
いるのですか？と
そういう人々は 世の中で
散々批判されるのです
あの人は人間ではないのだと
悪魔そのものだと 恐ろしいのだと
近寄るなと 親しくするなと
大変危ない人だと
そうではないでしょうか？
あっちこっちで人を殺したりすると
例えば 現在私が電車に乗っていると
みんなひどく怖がるのです
殺されるかもしれませんと
本当は私の話を聞く方々は
怖がっても良いのですが
精神的に殺される状態になりますから
電車に乗っている人には
何もしませんけど
みんな怖がってしまうのです
なぜかというと 分かりますから
今はそれ以上は言えません
やっぱり殺人する人は
みんな嫌うのです
私は殺人したことがないのだけど
動物も殺したことがないのだけど
どこか誰かさんが
殺人をしたのだから
それを何か私がやっているように
日本人が考えているのです
でもそれは頭の良いところだから
みんなの...
私は何も思わない
真実はやっぱり殺人する人は
みんな嫌うこと 怖がること
その人から逃げること
そういうことをするグループの人々は
どこかでアパートを借りても
周りの人々が来て
追い出してしまうのです
帰れと
それくらい社会から批判される
追い出される
殺人したり泥棒したりしたら
どうなるのですかというと
この社会で生きる権利さえ
失ってしまうのです
失ってしまって
自分の命もなくなって
しまってしまうのです 結局
ということは 生きている間は
並ならぬ苦しみを受けるのだと
では それから
もし来世があったならば
それは来世がないならば
どうするのですかと
もしあったならば その馬鹿者が
今世においても
ありとあらゆる批判やら
もう苦しみを受けて死んだところで
天界に行く訳ではないのです
来世があるならば
更にひどい「悪趣（あくしゅ）」
と言っている
苦しみの所に落っこちてしまうのだと
それで その人は
二倍損するのだと
「負ける」と「勝ち」という
言葉を使ってますけど
彼が２回負けるのだと
今世においても負けて
来世においても負けてしまうのだと
それで ある人が
殺生もしないで 慈しみのこころで
盗みをしないで 皆と自分の
持っている物を分かち合って
布施の行為をしながら
邪な行為をしないで
欲をきちんとコントロールして
正しい生き方で生きていて
嘘を言わないで 真実を語って
噂話をしないで
噂話というのは 人が別れるために
言うことだから
人の平和のために言葉を使って
人が仲良くするために言葉を使って
それで無駄話もしないで
意味のある言葉をしゃべって
余計な怒りと余計な欲を捨てて
危険な概念 危険な哲学
危険な思想を持たないで
正しい考え方を持って生活するのだと
そうするとどうなるのですかと
皆様から その人は素晴らしい人だと
信頼できる人だと
信頼される 褒められる
自分の今世における人生が
どんどん幸福になってしまう
仕事をしても 社会に入っても
何をしても
みんな信頼してくれますから
幸福になってしまう
それで もし来世があったならば
その人どうなりますかというと
当然なことで その人良い所に
生まれ変わってしまうのだと
素晴らしい所に
それで その人が
２倍勝てるのだと
今世においても勝ちを得て
来世においても勝ちを得るのだと
負けることがないのだと
それで
結論は
来世あろうがなかろうが
あなたの今世における
生き方を問います
ということなのです
ですから皆様も だいたい
来世あるかないかということに
それほどこだわらなくても良いのです
来世があるのだったら
お寺に来て お経を上げますと
そうでなければ来ませんと
ということは良くない
ということです
素晴らしいのは
来世があってもなくても
正しいことをする人なのです
清らかな生活をすることこそ
素晴らしいのです
泥棒をやったり
銀行強盗をやったり
不倫をやったりして生活するのは
どんなバカにもできることで
それはそんなに素晴らしいこと
ではないのです
素晴らしいのは この証明できない
考え方に頭を悩まさないで
我々は確実に正しい生き方を
することなのです
例えば よく
お寺の経営は大変必要ですから
お布施しなさいと言っているのです
そこで ご利益なければ
お布施はしません
ご利益も 二種類ありまして
現世に起きるご利益と
来世のご利益と
そこで とことんご利益の話を
言ってしまうのです
それでご利益を得るのだとしたら
お布施しましょうと
今 五千円お布施をしたら
来世においては
一億円儲かるのだったら
では 良いです あげます
とあげてしまうのだけど
あれはお布施にはならないのです
ただの悪い商売だけで
欲だけで
正しいお布施というのは
来世あろうがなかろうが
やっぱり良いことを
しなくてはいけない
人を助けることは
素晴らしいことであると
理由がなくても 例えばもうご飯を
食べられない お金がなくて
人が困っているのだと
その人には自分の力で収入を得ることは
できない状態にいるのだと
来世があるならば あなたに
ごはん一つ 弁当一つ
買って上げますと言うのは
飛んでもない話なのです
来世があろうがなかろうが
その人は苦しんでいるのだから
正しい人間というのは
「どうぞこの弁当を食べて下さい」と
そこでその人が「有難うございます」
と言うと
「（礼は）いい いい」
と言うことだと
いわゆる
自分は 何と言いますか
こういう良いことをさせて
頂いているのだと
風な気持ちで行うならば
それは本当に立派な生き方なのです
ですから 私は仏教の
どんな宗派でも構いませんけど
そういう風な話をした方が
良いのではないかと
来世やら 極楽の話やら
天国の話やら
そんなことは止めた方が
良いのではないかと
そんなことはあってもなくても
我々の今の生き方は
立派ですか（そうで）ないかと
で 次の考え方は
立派に生きることはなぜ悪いですかと
立派な人間らしき生き方
あるいは人間でありながら
人間を超えている生き方は
なぜ悪いのですかと
それにチャレンジしてほしいのです
そうすると
来世があろうがなかろうが
関係なく
自分が勝ちます
もし（来世が）あったならば
２倍勝ちますから
そこで一生下らない人生をして
ただ食べることだけに みんなの人生
それで終わってしまいから
食べて寝ることだけですから
もう何のロクなことも大事なこと
やっていないのだから
いえいえ仕事をしていますと
偉そうに言うかも知れませんが
あれは何のために
やっているのですか？
家賃を払って食べるためだから
寒いから服を買って
そこで便利だから結婚をするし
寂しいのだから子どもを作るし
それぐらいのことだから
そんな大胆なことではないのです
それは
何かおかしいのは 人間も
「それはとても大胆なことだ」と
「それは大変だ」
と思っているのです
僕は情けないと思っているのです
仕事をするということは
そんなに大変 大胆なことかと
そうではないし
子どもを作ることは？
子どもを育てること？
簡単なことなのです そんなことは
なぜ私はそういう風に言うかというと
そんなことは犬 猫もやっています
猿もやっています そんなことは
ミミズ
ミミズもやってますから
あなた方はミミズより
どこら辺が偉いかと
ミミズもちゃんと仕事をして
ご飯を食べています
頑張らなくては食べられませんから
ちゃんと交尾して卵を産むし
それは正しく育てるようにしておくし
鳥なんか見て下さい 一生懸命
子育てをやっているのではないですか？
いろんな種類の鳥がいます
ある種の鳥が卵を温め始めたら
全然もう巣から離れません
それでお父さんが大変です
ずっと餌を運んであげる
それでもう
ひよこが出たら それでも
お母さんが出ていけない
それでひよこを大きくする
お父さんの仕事は大変なのです
ある一種類の鳥がいるのです
一生懸命 餌を探して探して
もう四人分ぐらい
餌運ばなくてはいけないし
立派ではないですか それも
ですから そういうミミズも
やっていることで
猿もやっていることで
猿も自分の子どもたちに
どんな食べ物を食べた方が良いか
どこら辺はどんな危険がありますか
どういう風に年上の人に
挨拶しますかと
全部ちゃんと教えています
それで人間が 自分の子どもは
少し言うことを聞かないのだ
どうしようか どうしようと
カウンセラーの所に走ったりとか
あれはもう猿知恵がないから
なのです
ですから
これは真面目な話なのですが
猿にも劣る知恵があって
知識があって もう大変なことを
やっているのだと
我々は偉そうに生きているのだと
高層の建物を作っているのだと
こういうものは作っているのだと
言うのだけど
頭の悪いことというのは
日本では面白いことに
銀行が倒産するのです
一番知識のある
経済的な能力ある
すごい賢い 鋭い人々はだいたい
銀行の責任者になるはずですが
我々ぐらいと全く もしかすると
どうか分かりませんけれど
あんな膨大な金を動かしている
銀行も倒産する
皆様の貯金も大変危うい状態になると
だから おかしいのです
猿にも劣る
知恵しかあって「生きている」と
威張るんじゃないと
私は言いたいのです
ですから そういう人生をやっていて
突然 自分の子どもが
亡くなってしまったら
事故を起こして
突然自分の奥さんが
急に亡くなってしまったら
旦那さんが亡くなってしまったら
頭が狂ってしまうのです
狂うのは当たり前だから
もう既に狂っていたのだから
そこでお寺に走ってきて
葬式はお寺で行いますから
キリスト教徒や誰であろうが
だいたい日本では
お寺のお坊さんは大変なのです
どうやってこの阿呆を慰めて
あげられるか分かりませんから
また慰めてあげるにも やっぱり
常識がなければできないでしょう？
常識も「以下」だから
お寺では悩んでいる人を
慰めてあげるのは お寺の仕事です
それは分かっています
人が苦しんでいると
何とかもう助けてあげて
精神的な力を付けてあげるのは
我々の仕事なんです
ずっと二千五百年ぐらい
やっていますから この仕事は
そうなのですが ミミズにも
出来ることが出来ない人が来て
何とかしてくださいと
言っても どうにもならないのです
ですから やっぱり
何かひどい目に遭うまで待たないで
人間らしくまず生きていることが
大事なのです
そうすると 他の問題
全部解決するはずなのです
何が人間らしい生き方ですかと
それから何が人間を超えた
生き方ですかと
それを少々考えてみましょう
人間らしい生き方というのは
誰にも出来ることではないのです
例えば お金がない
それで 人をだましてお金を取ると
それは 人間らしい生き方
ではないのです
商売する それで
ボロ儲けをするのだと
それは 人間らしい生き方
ではないのです
なぜならば 我々のこころの中で
もう人間よりレベル低いのだから
かなり程度の低いこころがあるのです
自分さえ良ければ良いのだと
ですから すぐ人は
盗みに走ってしまうのです
銀行の偉い管理職に就いている人も
泥棒をするし
素晴らしい政治家も泥棒するし
泥棒とは 銀行強盗することだけが
泥棒ではないのです
例えば デパートに行ってちょっと
万引きすることだって泥棒です
あるいは自分の家破って家に入って
家にある何かお金を持っていく
それだけが泥棒ですよ？
冗談ではないのです
自分にふさわしくないお金を
持つことは泥棒なのです
自分の給料以外何とかごまかして
お金をもらったら
それは正真正銘の
盗みです
例えば 証券関係の仕事をしていると
取引所とか
そういう人々は色々やっては
いけないことが決まっているのです
自分で株を買って
ああだこうだとかあるみたいです
僕はあまりそういう世界は
知りませんけど
もしそういう人々が裏で
もう一応情報を知っているのだから
儲かろうとすると
すぐ儲かるのです
そういうことをやったならば
それは泥棒です
例えば 政治家には
大変な力があります
そこでその力を使って
色々なことをして
それに謝礼として
何か貰ってしまうのだと
それも泥棒です
だいたい我々はよくやっています
全然そういう覚えがないと
こころに聞いてみた方が良いのです
あるはずなのです
みんな「盗むな」と言った途端
何と言いますか
顔をこうやって隠して
何か道具を持って家を破っている人を
想像するかもしれませんけれど
では無いのです
ちゃんとネクタイをはめて
大変高級なネクタイはめて
大変高価なタイピンをつけて
やっています
女性も男性も
訪問販売したりとか
全く効き目のないものを
とても高価な薬だと言って
売り込んだりとか
そういうのは泥棒です
そんな話を延々とする
必要はないのだけど
だいたい我々は人間以下のことを
やっているのです
それで人間以下のことを
やらないで
人間と等しいことを
やってほしいのです
なぜなら動物は泥棒しません
すると思っていますか？しない
動物の世界では
そういう概念もないのです
では 野良猫は
盗んでいるのではないかと
いえ していないのです
野良猫は仕事をしているだけです
野良猫は自分で仕事をして
餌をもらわなくてはならない
それで「では仕事に行こう」
と言ったところで
何でもすぐ忘れる奥さん一人が
ドアを開けていたのだと
それは窓を開けているのだから
そこから入れるのだから
猫の心理から言えば入っても良いし
そこで魚一匹があるのだと
奥さんがテレビを見ているのだと
用意した魚はそのまま置いておいて
そこで「ああ こっちには餌が
あるのだから いただきます」と
頂いて帰ってしまうのです
それで奥さんが泥棒猫だと思って
追いかけて
何か石でも投げて
窓ガラスを割ってしまうと
下手ですから
投げるのは 女性は
そこで更に怒ってしまうし
それは決して 猫は泥棒を
やっているわけではないのです
人間はやっています
動物さえやらないことだから
嘘を付くこととか
我々はそういうことをやめて
まず人間らしく
生きていなくてはいけない
仏教ではとことんそれを教えるべきだと
私は思っています
堂々と「あんた方は猿だ」と
「人間ではないのだ」と
「人間になりなさい」と
言うぐらいの
自信はないだろうと思いますけど
私はもう好き勝手に
言いたい放題言いますけど
やっぱり日本のお寺の
状況を考えると
そんなことは言える場合ではないし
もう一生に一回しか寺に来ないし
それも誰か死ななかったら来ないし
その時はそんなことを
言う場合ではないし
それで悪いのはお互い様なのです
それで まず人間らしくなる
これから人間のレベルを
アップします
どうやってアップしますかというと
自分の仕事をして
ごはんを食べて 家族を養って
平和で生活する
それは普通の人間の生き方
でも自分には少々余分なお金がある
それで どこかへ行って
下らない遊びをしないで
これはもう一人の人のために
使いましょうと
障害者やらいろんな困っている人々は
いっぱいいるのだから
そういうことにも使いましょうと
自然を守るために使いましょうと
生命を守るために使いましょうと
とするならば
それは少し人間のレベルが
高くなったことです
自分にお金があれば そのお金で
どこかへ行って遊ぶことは
自由であるし
どこか飲み屋さんに行って
お金がなくなるまで
すごい高いパブなんかに行って
飲むこともできるし
自分の自由です
自由なのに
やっぱりそれは人々のために
使いましょうと
例えば 隣の家で
人が急に病気になって
大変困って 泣いているのだと
みんな各家族 各家庭だから
隣の人はどうなっても良いと
相手のことに口は出しませんと
自分勝手に生活することは
別にできるし
そうではなくてやっぱり
困っている人を助けてあげましょうと
いかがですか？元気ですかと
もし老人の方が独り住まいで
一人で住んでいるならば
良く行って 面倒をみて
「どうですか？」とか
そういう風にもう
もう少し高いことをすること
それで人間性が上がってしまうのです
それだけでは終わりません
例えば 我々に誰かが悪口を言ったと
そうすると どうなるのですか？
怒るでしょう 普通
批判されましたと
それでひどく腹が立って
しまうのです
それは自然なのです
批判した人を恨む
それは全く人間の自然法則です
自分がカンカンに怒って
なぜならば あの人は私のことを
良く批判するのだと
私をけなして馬鹿にしているのだと
だから腹が立っているのだと
良く分かります
それは人間どうであろうが
そうなるのです
そこで人間性を超えてほしいのです
馬鹿にされても 批判されても
けなされても
怒らないこと
それは難しいのです
難しいのだけど そういう風に
「あ そうですか
すみませんでした」と
これから気をつけますと
良く私の未熟な所を教えて頂きまして
本当に有難うございますと
正直なこころで 謙虚なこころで
言えるならば
その人は普通の人間よりは
違うのではないですか？
例えば男性の場合は
いくら結婚していても
いろんな美人が見えると
やっぱり頭の中でいろんな
考え方が生まれるのです
あの人美人です あの人も
とても綺麗ですとか
少し話でもしてみようかとか
それはごく普通です
女性は怒るかもしれませんが
これは生理学的にそういう
遺伝構造なのです 男性というのは
すぐ美しい女性を見たら
ちょっかいを出してしまうのです
奥さんがいくら腹が立っても
もうどうしようもないことなのです
それは普通であって
遺伝的なプログラムであって
それである人がこうするのです
私は結婚して家族を持っていると
私は自由自在に遊び回ってしまったら
やっぱり相手の人の機嫌も
取らなくてはいけないのだから
いろいろプレゼントをあげたり
物をあげたりしなくてはいけない
それで自分の財布は
減ってしまってしまうし
やっぱりそのお金は
家族の幸福のために
使わなくてはいけないと
余計な欲は
もう大変危険であると
ロクなものにはならないと
ですから
あの人は美人であるかも
しれませんけど
自分には関係はありませんと
全く他の人に対しては
欲のこころは作らない
それはやっぱり男性は
頑張らなくてはできないのです
そうすると普通の男性よりは
普通の人間よりは その人は
高いレベルにいるのです
そういう風に
まず人間になって
猿から進化して
それから人間性を
できるだけ
高いレベルに持っていく
それを究極のレベルまで
レベルアップする方法は
仏教のお釈迦様の教えなのです
特に初期仏教の話は
そういうことです
今言ったことだけではないのです
まだまだ色々あるのです
こころに怒りやら 憎しみやら
妬みやら
微かにでも埋まらない所まで
こころを磨いておく
真理はありのまま見える所まで
こころを磨いてみる
そこで 結局
神々 人間 みんなを超えて
出世間的な境地までこころを持っていく
それは仏道です
神々を拝むのではなくて
神々を乗り越えてしまうのです
梵天とかとても高次元の
生命がいるのです
皆様の分かる言葉で言うならば
観音さんもいて お不動さん
（不動明王）もいるのだと
私が言うのは
拝むなと 乗り越えなさいと
観音様どうか助けてくださいと
そんな もう
弱いこころで人間はダメです
よし 私は観音様を乗り越えるのだと
と言うぐらいの
力強い生き方が必要です
神社を拝まなくても大丈夫だと
観音様を拝んで
お願いします お願いしますと
と言わなくも大丈夫だと
そういう風な
すごいこころを作ってほしいのですけど
ですから
ポイントは来世 死後どうなるか
ということではなくて
我々はどう生きていますか
人間で生まれたのだから
その仕事を果たしましたかと
仕事を果たさないで死んでしまったら
もう可哀想なのです
良いことになるはずがないのです
人間で生まれたのは 鮭のように
僕は昨日もそのたとえを
言ったのですが
鮭のように生活するため
ではないのです
最近は鮭が気に入って
よくそのたとえを出すのです
鮭が川に産まれて
下って 海に行って
3年間ぐらい 無茶苦茶
食べているのです
結婚もしない
遊びもしない
ただひたすら食べる
食べて生まれた時は
ほんの小さなものですけど
３年経つとかなり巨大
そこまで大きくなるまで
食べて食べて
もう食事は終わりましたと
３年間食事をして
それで 産まれた川に戻るのです
戻ると必死で川を上る
上ってどうなるのですか？
卵を産む
産んだらどうなるのですか？
死ぬ
それだけ
たったそれだけで生きているのです
卵を産んで死ぬために
なんて悲しいかと
なんてくだらないかと
そういう風に見てほしいのです
「美しい」ではなくて
ああ美しい この鮭たちは自分の
子孫を残すために愛情があってとか
あんなデタラメ嘘ばかりなのです
僕はテレビで見たのだから
テレビの
何と言いますか
話しているのだから
説明しているのだから
とても文学的な言葉が並んで
みんなだまされます
僕はだまされません
この馬鹿の阿呆の話は聞きませんと
聞かないで鮭をじっと
見ているのです
そこで必死で川を上るのです
途中で死んでしまうし 怪我するし
熊に捕らわれるし
もうありとあらゆる
危険があるのです
結局ゴールに行った鮭が
卵を産む
産んで死ぬと
自分の子どもの顔さえ
見ることはできないのです
そこでその子どもが何か
やってくれるとしたら 良いのだけど
その子どもは同じく川を下って
海に行って ３年間食べて
また上がって また卵を産む
あれは何をやっているのですかと
いい加減やめなさいと
それをずっと繰り返すのです
そこで皆様も同じです
鮭と何も変わりがないのです
決まっているパターンで生まれて
決まっていることをして
決まっていますから 全部
何歳で小学校か 何歳で中学か
何歳で高校か 何歳で大学かと
それで就職して それで結婚して
子どもをつくって
歳をとって ゲートボールをやって
死んでしまう
それで威張ってしまうのです
「我々は人間だ」とか
威張るんじゃない
鮭と全然変わりがないのだから
一応
変わりがないでしょう
なぜならば 人間の世界を見ても
やっぱり ゲートボールまでできて
そこでボケて寝たきりになって 死ぬ
そこまで生きる人もいて
途中で終わる人もいるのです
結婚できない人もいるし
結婚しても喧嘩して別れて
また独身で人生を終わる人もいるし
学校に行ったのだけど
勉強できなくて落第する人もいるし
仕事に就いたのだけど
仕事をクビになる人もいるし
突然途中で癌やら何か病気にかかって
それで終わりという人もいるし
そういうことが何もなかったとしても
事故とかに出遭って消える人もいるし
どこが違うのですか 鮭とは？
人間には何か鮭にできないことが
できるはずなのです
それをやってほしい
ということなのです
それなのです
愛のこころを作ることやら
怒りをなくすこと
欲を消すこと
こころの汚れを断つこと
いわゆる解脱を
できれば体験することなのです
こんな下らないことをやめなさいと
ずっと繰り返して繰り返して..
ということなんです
ですから 結局
死んでから...
どうなるか分からないという
はっきりした知識に基づいて
そういう生き方を作るならば
それは今日の話のテーマの
ポイントだと思います
皆様はそういう話ではなくて
違うものを聞きたがっていた
とは分かっていますけど
そういう違う話も話せます
話せるのだけど
私は嘘を言っているか
本当のことを言っているかとは
皆様には分からない
私には嘘でも全く本当のように
話すことはできるのです
ですから本当に死後の働き
そういう構造
生命の次元論
どこでどうやって
どういう風になるかと
なぜ人間が死んで
それで終われないかとか
本当に終わるか終わらないかとか
そういうのは話せます
話せますけど
ただ
信じるしかないのです
そういう能力は人間の脳細胞には
やっぱりプログラム
されていないのです
もし聞きたければ
まだ時間がありますから
どんどん説明はします
答えから言います
「死んだらどうなるか」と
僕は第一部では
「分かりません」とはっきりと
どんな仏教の宗派のお坊さんが
「ああだこうだ」と言っても
本当は分かりません そのお坊さんも
そういういろんな宗派の
一番偉いお坊様方がいるのです
聞いたら「どうなるか」と
言うのです 偉そうに合掌でもして
「やっぱり人間は亡くなったら
こうなります」
あれは嘘です 知らないあの人も
一応
私と同じです
そこで物事は済みませんから
「亡くなったらどうなるのですか」
その答えから言うならば
亡くなったら それでは
消えないのです
それはとても良いと
思っているでしょう？
良いという訳ではないのです
考えてみて下さい
鮭のように自分が生まれたと
そこで卵を産むために３年間食べて
それからずっと何も食べないで
何百キロでも良いのだから
川を渡って卵を産んで死ぬと
あれは面白いと思いますか？
それはずっと繰り返して下さいと
言われたら楽しいですか？
我々も鮭と同じだから
この人生はどこに生まれても
同じなのです
馬鹿なことを繰り返して
繰り返して死ぬ
それでまたもう一回
トライして下さいと
また同じ馬鹿なことを
繰り返して死ぬ
またトライして下さいと
また同じことをやって死ぬ
それでもみんな
「生きていきたい」
と思っているのだけど
それは頭が悪いからです
無明だからです
無知だからです
無明が消えてしまったら
その問題はだいたい分かります
とにかく
話がややこしくなりますので
生命が死んだら
そこで消えない
その消えない訳は
皆様は知っているのです
知っているでしょう？
別に...
知っています
なぜ人が死んでしまったら
消えないかと それで
皆様はそれだけは知っています
では聞きます
死にたい人がどなたか
いらっしゃいますか？
ここに？
今 死にたい人がどなたか
いらっしゃらないでしょう？
やっぱり人生がいくら苦しくても
死にたくはないでしょう？
では 私は死にますと
例えば すごいご馳走があって
それをこれから「いただきます！」と
気持ち良く食べるような感じで
では これから「私は死にます！」と
すごい気持ち良く死にたい人は
一人もいません
自殺する馬鹿がいるのですが あれは
すごく気持ち良く万々歳で
自殺するのではないのです
嫌で嫌で
トコトンもう
自分で生きていられなくて
自殺をするのです
ただ死にたい 「楽しい」
と思って死ぬ人は
一人もいないのです
だからそこなのです
皆様は知っているのです
死んでも消えない訳が
これは「死にたくない」からです
それはすごいエネルギーなのです
あの鮭が
どんなエネルギーで
どんな指令を受けて
誰の命令であんな馬鹿なことを
しているのですか？
例えば 鮭ではなくて
ペンギンのことを考えても
とても長い距離を歩いて行って
飛べばいいのに
飛べないのです やっぱり
それで餌をいっぱい食べてきて
卵を温めるのです
その間次の...
夫婦でやっていますから
餌を取りにまた何百キロも歩くのです
あれは
別にそんなに苦労をしないで
卵を産まなければ良いのに
あれは何の指令で
何の命令で 誰の命令で
衝動は何ですか？
みんなこの「死にたくない」
という衝動なのです
「死にたくはない」と
それで一生懸命頑張っているのです
人間も同じです
いろんなことをするのです
楽にいれば良いのに
何か食べてしまったら
少し身体が疲れるのだから
少しひと眠りでもして
昼寝でもする暇がないのだから
奥さん以外には
ニコニコ笑って
楽にリラックスして
のんびり生きていられますか？
そうは生きていられません
必死でいろんなことをやっているのです
それは何のためかというと
生きているためなのです
研究するわ 実験するわ
いろんな発明するわ
商売するわ それで失敗するわ
倒産するわ また儲かるわ
いろんなことをやっているのです
すべての働きはこの
「死にたくはない」と
この「死にたくない」という
この衝動があると
我々は何かをする
これはすごいエネルギーです
すごいエネルギーを持っていると
必ず結果が出てくるのです
そのまま消える訳にはいきません
それは因果の論なのです
全く消える訳ではないのです
消えることはできません
ですからこの
21世紀の社会を我々が作ったのも
今 息苦しい世界を作ったのも
我々は「生きていきたい」と必死で
やっていたからなのです
だいたい人殺しも
「自分が生きていきたい」から
やっているのです
おかしいことに
あれは「自分の幸福のため」に
やっているのです
自分がそれで消えると大変な
ひどい目に遭うと分かっていたら
人殺しはしませんから
銀行強盗もそれによって
「自分が幸福になる」
と思ってやっているのです
だからこの「生きていきたい」
「死にたくない」という
この強烈な衝動が
ある限り
我々は止まりたくはない
それで死ぬ瞬間でも
「バイバイさよなら」と
死ぬ賢い人がいないのです
死ぬ時でも
「一秒でも生きていきたい」と
ですから死ぬ瞬間で
失望で死ぬのです
「ああ負けた」と
「結局ゲームオーバー」だと
ゲームセンターにいらっしゃった
経験があるでしょう？
私は行ったことがないのだけど
百円 二百円を入れて
ゲームをやっていると
すぐ
"GAME OVER"と出てくるのです
上手な人は何分間は持つかも
しれませんが
でも いくら持っても
必ず"GAME OVER"という
文字が出ます
でもまたやりたいのです
そこで
お母さんたちがもしかすると
子どもと一緒に
そういう遊ぶ所に行った
経験があると思いますけど
子どもに百円あげたら
子どもは何とかそれで遊んでいて
すぐ"GAME OVER"でしょう？
でも それであの子は満足しますかと
満足しない
「お母さん もっとやりたい」
と言うでしょう？
それでもう一つ百円をあげなくては
いけないのです その場合は
そうでなければ
子どもはうるさいのだから
そういう論理です
死後の論理も
死ぬ瞬間で"GAME OVER"と
サインが出たら
「まあ良し 負けた 終わった」と
覚悟を決めれば良いのに
やっぱり悔しいのです その瞬間は
そこで「生きていきたい」
という すごい...
エネルギーが パワーが生まれる
そこで違う形で
そのエネルギーはまた
続くのです
あのお経で言ったような
何か死んでしまったら
その人の魂のような
向こうに移るという
ことではないのです
単なるエネルギーの連続性であって
ただ連続していくだけなのです
そこで仏教も結構 嘘は言ってますから
輪廻転生の話をするとやっぱり
みんな良いことをして
良い所に生まれ変わりたいとか
それで
そういう風に思っている場合も
ありますけど
そんなにも面白くないのです
輪廻転生も
それで自分が
例えば ここで良いことをして
どこかで良い所に
生まれ変わったとしても
それほど実感がないのです
他の人なのです
その幸福を得られるのは
結局
では皆様はもう今 私は少し
おかしくなるかもしれませんけど
だいたいお越しの人々は
テーラワーダ仏教を良く
聞いていらっしゃるのだから
話は分かると思いますけど
初期仏教の立場から言えば
輪廻転生の話なのです
一回で成仏するという話は
ないのです
輪廻の中で生まれて死んで
生まれて死んで
ずっとグルグル回っているのだと
解脱するまでという考え方です
僕はその立場から
今しゃべっているのです
それで
今 皆様方はとても幸福でしょう？
日本で生まれて何も問題ないし
平和な国でお互いに戦いもしないし
食べる物にも困ることはないし
仕事をすればお金も入るし
年金でも生活できるし
何も問題ないのです
その楽な生活するためにやっぱり
過去生で何か良いことを
していなかったら得られないのです
そこで過去生であの人は一生懸命
過去生でいた人が
人が誰でも良いのだけど
一所懸命良いことをして
今 皆様方はその幸福を
得ているのです
何か自分が過去生で良いことをした
という実感は全くないでしょう？
そういう所は
この輪廻転生は
そんなにも
とても気持ち良い話でもないのです
単なるエネルギーの
繰り返しというか
一つのエネルギーが消えると
それなりに適当なエネルギーが
生まれてくる
そこら辺の働きは
かなり理解は難しいのです
僕は 少し理解できるように
しゃべると難しくなりますけど
自分勝手にしゃべるならば
簡単にしゃべれますけど
では 死ぬ瞬間のことを説明します
これから
私たちは身体とこころが 今
人間だと思っているのです
今 人間だと思っているのは
この脳細胞と神経と
そちらの働きと
身体という物体の働きなんです
その二つとも
ここに置いておかなくてはいけないのです
例えば 皆様方はかなり
勉強なさっているかもしれません
博士号も２つ ３つくらい
持っているかもしれません
それは全部 教育 知識というのは
身体のものなのです
身体が壊れてしまったら
無くなってしまうのです
ですから我々の知識も
身体も
脳みそも
死ぬ時はここで置いておくのです
もったいない話ですけど
持っていけないのです
それより この人間として
この生きる衝動というか
この生きるエネルギーですか
生き方でそこだけ
最後の瞬間に決まり手に
なってしまうのです
どれぐらい どんな大学で
勉強したかとか
それはもう関係ない
いわゆる「性格」です
分かりやすく言えば
例えば 死ぬ前にリンゴを食べたと
もう一人がリンゴを食べなかったと
死ぬ時は リンゴを食べたか
食べなかったということではなくて
リンゴに対してあなたは
どんな態度を取ったかと
それは来世を決めるポイントです
あなたは金持ちで生活しましたかと
それは聞かない
あなたは持っていた金に対する
どういう態度 どういう性格
どういうアプローチがあったかと
ですから 愚か者も 賢者も
金持ちも 貧しい人も
死ぬ時は同じということは
こういうことです
貧しい人が死ぬ時も同じであって
あなたは自分の生き方に対して
どういう態度をとって
いたのですかと
それで
来世は
決めてしまうのです
だから 我々は生き方
とても大事なポイントです
貧しいか豊かということは
全然影響はない
とても良い大学に入って
勉強しましたと
大学に入らなかったと
それは全く関係ない
赤ちゃんか 大人か
それは関係ない
子どもが亡くなったのだからと
悩む必要はないのです
それぞれの人が どういう生き方
物事に対するどういう
アプローチを持っていたかと
だいたい子どもが亡くなったら
結構良いと思います
なぜならば子どもはそれほど
徹底した執着とか
それほどないのですから
楽に死ぬのです 死ぬ時は
もしかすると良い所に生まれ変わる
可能性は大人より多いのです
例えば いっぱい問題がある人が
いっぱい商売をやって
いろんな所でいろんな商売して
大変忙しくて
大変社会的に有名で
財産・富がいっぱいありまして
名誉がありまして
二十四時間忙しくて
そういう人は死ぬ時も
死ぬ暇さえないのです
あれをやらなくては
これをやらなくてはと
病院に行く時でも
電話二、三本持っていくぐらい
そこでも秘書やらいろいろな人々と
一緒に病院にいるとか
私はそういう人々は
見たこともあります
病院でもきちんと事務所を
やっているのです
そこで
死んでしまったら
良い所に行くと思っていますか？
行けないのです
なぜかというと
かなり執着しているのです
物事に
（その）アプローチは
良くないのです
そういうことでとにかく
死ぬ時は
我々の勉強した知識も
ほとんど
役に立っていない
身体は役に立たないことは
ものすごく分かって
いらっしゃるのです
誰でも
死ぬ時はもう身体が壊れるから
死ぬのだから
こころが壊れません
死ぬ時でもこころは活動していますから
身体が壊れることに
我々はただ単に
「死ぬ」ということを
言っているのです
その時は
こころは自由に活動できるし
その我々の生き方によって
我々の好き嫌いによって
何かの現象が見えてくる
その現象に対する
その人のアプローチによって
次にそのエネルギーは
また活動し始める
例えば 小さい時から
人が亡くなったら
阿弥陀様がお迎えに来ると
その話を聞いていたならば
信じていたならば
いくらかリラックスする
それでその人に
最後の瞬間で
自分の頭にある概念だから
そういうものは見える
とする
見えても
それで極楽浄土に行く
ということではなくて
極楽浄土はあるかないか
分かりませんし
その見えるものに対して
どういうアプローチを取るかと
それによって決められます
例えば
一生 全然
お寺なんかには行かないとか
ただ話聞いただけだったりとか
ちょっと阿弥陀様の絵だけ
見たことがあるとか
自分の家はそういう宗派の家だと
思っていて 見えたと
そうしたら その人は
怖くなるかもしれませんし
かなり驚くかもしれませんし
びっくりするかもしれませんし
ひどく不安になるかもしれませんし
あれ？私は死んでしまうのではないかと
これで
あるいは「何だこれ？」と
驚くかもしれません
そのことによって
もう次は決められてしまいます
ですから 本当の
再生の法則というのは
かなりややこしいのです
なぜこういう話をしたかというと
チベット仏教では
「死者の書」という
どうでも良い本があります
日本では人気があるのですが
（その本が）あって とことん
人々に教えてあげてしまうのです
死後はこうなります
ああなりますと
そういういろんな概念を
頭に入れてしまったら
そういうすべてどんな概念も
現実にこころが映してしまうのです
身体がある限りは
例えば 「阿弥陀様を見たい」と思っても
皆様には見えないのです
身体で邪魔されているのです
身体から離れたら
阿弥陀様でも良いし
悪魔でも良いし
神様でも良いし
何でも見えるのです
なぜ見えるかというと
こころはそのものを作ってしまう
自分で自分を認識する
そういうかなり分かりにくい
法則があるのです
勉強すれば
とても簡単ですけど
分かりますけど
自分で作ったものに対して
自分がどんな態度を取るかと
そのエネルギーによって
来世は決まる
ですから 私が言うのは
安心するなと
例えば 死ぬ時は阿弥陀様を見ても
良かった これから極楽浄土だと
そうではなくて やっぱりこころの成長は
とことん効くのです
最後までも
僕はこのチベットの「死者の書」の
そこで法則が間違っているところ
いっぱい見つかりましたから
彼らの表の言い方は正しいのです
例えば人が死んでしまって
悪い所に生まれ変わったら
困るのだと
ですから とことん頭に
良い概念
仏様の世界のこと
あの世のことを
概念を叩き込んでおこうと
叩きこんでしまったところで
幻覚が現れる時は
何とか良い所に生まれ変わる
のではないか
という狙いなのですが
その部分は良いのですが
やっぱり それだけでは
ダメなのです
なぜそんなことを言うのかというと
私は日本でいろんなことを見ている
例えば たまにこういう
経験もあったのです
ある日 どこか
その日もやっぱり自分の国から
帰ってきた時ですが
電車を降りていくと
お母さんが小さい赤ちゃんを
抱っこしていたんです
女の子です
抱っこしなくては歩けないぐらい
少し歩けるくらい １歳ぐらいかな
あの子が 私を見た瞬間で
いきなりかなり親近感を持ちました
本当は
変な人を見たら怖くなる
驚くのは普通ですけど
そうではなくて
かなり親近感を持っているのです
子どもは後を見ているし
抱っこされていますから
母が前を見ているし
それで
僕はそれを分かって
ではこの子とやっぱり
何かコミュニケーション
しなくてはいけないのだと
それほど親近感を持って
仲良くしているのだから
それで言葉ではなくて
とにかく
その子どものこころと私は何とか
通じ合ったのです
子どもは更に
とても元気になって
反射的に母から下りて
私の所に行きたがってしまうのです
母はまだ知らない
私と話していることさえ知らない
なぜならば口でしゃべっている
訳ではないのだから
とにかく
何とか下りてしまったのです
下りて 僕は他のホームに
行っているのだけど
子どもがあっち走ってこっち
走っているのは僕は見えるのです
それは私の姿を探しているのですけど
そこで子どもを追っかけていると
お母さんが私を見たのです
僕はもうホームに
上がっているのを
そうしたらあのお母さんがかなり
怖くなってしまったのです
怖くなったらすぐ子どもを引っ張って
他の所に行ったのです
そこでこの２人が同じ対象を見て
二つの態度なのです
子どもはまだ死んで
間もないのだから
過去の何とか覚えがあっただろう
と思いますし
お母さんはもう
長い間人生ですから
やっぱり宗教的な話は全く
聞いたこともないだろうと思う
見て それで驚いたり
怖がったりする
そういう人はやっぱりもう
死ぬ時は危ないのです
聖なる世界に対しては
怖いのだったら
死ぬ時はもし間違ってでも
阿弥陀様が
間違ってでもその人に現れたら
どうなるのですかと
私も阿弥陀様に会ったことが
ないのだから
阿弥陀様も馬鹿なことをするか
どうかは分かりませんけど
もし阿弥陀様も 冗談であの人にも
顔を見せてあげようと思ったら
あのお母さんがひどく
怖がってしまいます
怖くなったら
怖い波動にふさわしい
次元に落ちる
ですから
最終的に言いますけど
来世は 我々はキリスト教か
仏教かで決めるものではないのです
浄土真宗か 禅宗か
それで決めるものでもないのです
上座部仏教は阿弥陀様を
信じていないのだから地獄ですと
そういう風に決まるものではありません
それはあくまでも普遍的な法則で
行うものです
我々は
最後にどんな態度を取るかと
どんなアプローチをするかと
そこを知っているのだから
お釈迦様はとことん
落ち着きなさいと
こころを乱すことはするなと
私を信じなかったら
地獄に落ちますと
そういう正真正銘の馬鹿な
嘘は言っていないのです
もし宗教で言っているならば
自分の宗教を信じなかったら
地獄に落ちますと言うならば
その宗教は「完全に」
間違っているのです
全くインチキ宗教なんです
生命は死んでからもまた
命が続くことがあるならば
それは
あくまでも普遍的な宇宙的な
法則でなければいけません
ジーザス様を信じなかったら
地獄に落ちますと言ったら
それはもう大変間違っている考え方で
だから何を信じるかということは
残念ながら死後の決め手には
ならないのです
ですから上座部仏教を信じている人々も
必ず亡くなったら
とても良い所に生まれ変わります...
それはないのです
私たちは自分の国では
そういう脅しは良く言います
あんた方仏教の家族で
生まれたのだから
もう天国に行くと
思っているのですか？
冗談ではないのだと
そんな悪い事ばかりして
下らない事ばかりしているのだから
もう地獄でしょうと
ただ形だけで三帰依をしたり
戒律を 五戒を言ったりしても
何の意味もないのだと
言います はっきりと皆に
葬式の時でも
だいたいそういう話です
たまに私は葬式の中でこう言うのです
だいたい亡くなった時は
お坊さんに説教できる位のことを
やっておきなさいと
あまりにも下らない
何もしないで死んだ人の場合は
何も言うことないのです
人の悪口言う訳にはいきませんし
人が亡くなってしまったら
私は少し気が強いのだから
堂々と（人が）亡くなって
悩んでいる人々の前で
あなた方もこういう風に
亡くなりますと みんな
何か自分が死なないような感じで
泣いているのだけど
死なないと思っているのですかと
みんなが死ぬのですから
なぜ泣くのですかと
誰でもこんな目に遭いますと
泣く人はあまりにも
バカバカしいのだと
泣く場合は
「あの人は可哀想に死んでしまった」と
「私はこっちで生きているのに...」
と感じるでしょう？
自分も可哀想に死ぬのに
ですから こういうことを
ハッキリ言うのです
そういう風に（自分も）
死ぬのですから
だいたい
葬式にお坊さんたちを呼ぶのだから
私たちは何か
しゃべらなくてはいけない
ですから しゃべれるぐらい
５分ぐらい １０分でも
しゃべれるぐらいの内容のことを
しておきなさいと
必ず死にますと
そうでない人生は虚しいですと
向こうは だいたい 堂々と
こういう失礼な話を言う世界だから
上座部仏教の世界というのは
誰も腹が立って「では明日から
そのお坊さんにはお布施はしません」
ということにはなりません
だいたいみんなやっぱり
「よく言ってくれました」と
「普通のお坊さんはごまかしばっかり
やっている」という風に
褒める場合は多いのですけど
やっぱりはっきりと言っておかなくては
人間は幸福にならないのです
そういうことで それから
生命のいろんな次元があるのです
皆様 地獄を知ってますか？
どういう世界かと
地獄の世界は
日本の仏画等にもあります
あの人々はもしかすると（地獄に）
行ったことがあるでしょう...
仏画を見たら「行ったことがない」
と分かったのだけど 私は
皆様も結構行ったことがある
と思いますけど
思い出して下さい
地獄ってどんなものかと
もし過去生を思い出せるならば
それは簡単に思い出せます
瞑想でもして
自分の過去を思い出すことを
するならば
過去で自分が何をやっていたかと
見えます
この地獄という次元があるのです
それは
不思議な次元で
大変低次元ですけど
それから徐々に
たくさん生命の次元があるのです
我々は三次元でいるのだから
他の次元何一つも 今の脳細胞で
今の眼では体験することは
できないのです
どういうことかというと
人間を見て 地獄を
理解しなくてはいけないのです
ですから 日本の仏画でも
地獄としてやっぱり描いているのは
人間の世界なのです
すごく面白くないのだけど
もっと恐ろしく描いた方が良いのに
こういう
たまに人間世界を見ると
いつでも喧嘩したり
大変恐ろしい生活をしている
人々がいるのです
鉄砲を持っているわ
何か人を刺す物を持っているわ
喧嘩だけしているわ
マフィアみたい やくざみたいに
いつ殺されるか分からないし
もう自分も堂々と相手を
殺さなくてはいけないし
いろいろお金を取ったりするし
それで人を脅したりするわ
他人の家に火をつけるわ
そこで自分の親分からも殴られるわ
それなのに その親分にすごく
徹底的に誠意でしがみついている
その生活と我々の生活を
比べてみて下さい
我々は喧嘩はイヤ
相手が少し気持ち悪いことをしても
やっぱり失礼なことを言うのは嫌
なぜならば後から
問題が出てくるのだから
そんな関わりは嫌だと
それで平和でいたい
もし兄弟でも喧嘩するならば
すぐそれはもう
なくなってほしいと
夫婦が喧嘩すると子どもは
やっぱりそれは嫌なのです
夫婦は仲良くしてほしいと
思ってしまうし
そういう次元二つを考えて下さい
人間の次元
悪いことをやっている人々は
あれは面白いですか？
人を殺して面白いですかと
人殺しに行って
自分の眼が消えてしまったと
手が一つ無くなったと
日本刀でやられて
指は一本無くなったと
それでも平気であの恐ろしい
あのグループにいるのです
その中にあるこころの
次元が分かるのです
あの人々は
あれでしか生きていられないのです
平和で仲良く 皆に優しい
生き方はできないのです
つまらなくて
刺激がないのです
だから死の刺激 恐怖の刺激
怒りの刺激
激痛の刺激で
生きているのです
プロレスリングとかしている人々は
あれはとても気持ち良く
やっているのです
身体はボロボロで 怪我だらけで
早死にするし
それでもしているでしょう？
あれは何が面白いのですか？と
どこかで普通のトラック
運転手さんでもやれば
もっと平和で生きていられるのに
お金がいっぱい入っても 別に
何のこともないのだから
ラクをする時間はないのだから
毎日訓練しなくてはいけないのだから
毎日闘わなくてはいけない
ボクサーとか考えてみて下さい
ああいう痛みの刺激で
生きているのです
たまに人が死ぬ時は
こころはそういう次元に
落ちてしまうのです
ある所に生まれる
生まれたら そこの食べ物は
怒り
恐怖
激痛
そういうものを食べて
生きているのです
ですから 我々と同じ
口（くち）がないのです
口がなければごはんは食べられません
おにぎりでも
でも 怒りを食べるために
口は要りませんでしょう？
そこで地獄というのは
そういう風に
激痛
恐怖
並みならぬ苦しみを
食として 餌として
取っている次元なのです
もし死ぬ瞬間で
自分のこころの次元が
そういう風に
痛みを快感にするように
なってしまったら もう危ない
別に仏画で描いているような
この地球の中に
地獄という何とかがあって そこで...
そういう話は我々に分かりやすく
言っている物語なのです
そこでずっとお互いに怒り合って
お互いに殺し合って
生きているのです
そこで皆様考えたことがありますか
地獄に行ってしまったら
人間の
仏話の中であります
地獄に行ったら鬼たちが
舌を抜くとか
人なんか あの溶岩みたいな
窯の中に入れて煮たりするのだと
そういうことをすると
死ぬでしょう？
例えば 鬼たちが
白く熱くなったこの鉄の玉を
お腹が空いたと言ってしまったら
それを食べさせるのだと
それで内臓は全部燃やしてしまって
下から落っこってしまうのだと
そんなことだとしたら
当然死ぬでしょう？
そういう話は 我々に
分かりやすく言うだけで
そういう生命ではないのです
とにかく身体の 食べると
いうことは ああいう風に
死ぬ程苦しみを味わうことなのです
だから一回でも 我々は
事故を起こして死にかけたならば
病気になってすごい苦しみを
味わったことがあるならば
皆様方 誰かが
それは毎日毎日 瞬間瞬間
味わわなくてはいけない状態
それでなぜ死ねないかというと
あれは
餌なのです
だから死ぬ訳はないのです
ご飯を食べて誰が死ぬのですか？
死にませんから
激痛を食にしている
死の恐怖を食にしている
そこで その死の恐怖が
得られれば得られるほど
この地獄にいる人々の
生命は延びるのです
もし瞬間でも
「死の恐怖は消えてしまった」
と思ったら 死んでしまうのです
食べ物はなくて
そこまで そこにいるのです
ですから 寿命は書いていない
天界というのはどういうものか
というと その逆に
楽しみ
を食にしている人々なのです
ですから 地獄よりは
天界の方が良いと
みんな思っているのだけど
結局 ちょっとした
次元の差なのです
餓鬼道の話はだいたい日本で
大変人気があるのですから
日本仏教では人間と餓鬼道の話
しかないようにも感じますけど
私の悪口ですけど
何かそんな話ばかりするとみんな
亡くなったら餓鬼道に行ってしまう
そういうケースもありますから
何かどこかで幽霊で現れたとか
あれは餓鬼道です
あれは物惜しみの
快感です
いつでも
あれをやれば良い
これをやれば良い
あれがあったら良い
これをやったら良いという風に
我々は悩んでいる状態があります
その時も 我々のこころから
そういう何かすごい
「満たされてない」という
エネルギーを出しているのです
そのエネルギーで食をしている
次元がいるのです
いつでも「食べたい 食べたい」とか
人間の言葉で言うならば
「ああ お金があれば良い
お金があれば良い」とか
「もっときれいになれば良い
きれいになれば良い」とか
「もっと健康的になれば良い」と
我々は良く思ってしまうでしょう？
あれは餓鬼道のエネルギー
の次元なのです
もし死ぬ時も
あれをしておけば良かった
これをやっておけば良かった
もっと金を儲けておけば良かったとか
そういう満たされていない
ひどく渇いているような
エネルギーで死んでしまったら
例えば 阿弥陀様を見たところで
やっぱりもっと丁寧にお寺に行って
お寺参りした方が良かったとか
思ってしまったら もう
そういう次元に行ってしまうのです
そこで その生命がずっと
「ない ない ない」という
苦しみでいるのです
その苦しみで苦しんでいるか
どうか分かりませんけど
それは「食」にしているのです
だから 例えば餓鬼道の餓鬼たちが
もし瞬間でもお腹が
満腹になってしまったら
死ぬのです
お腹が「今日は満腹だ」と
思ったら その瞬間に死ぬ
「ああ良かった」と思ったら死ぬ
だから死にたくないのだから
みんな
そうは思わない
人間もそうでしょう？
例えば人間が人間の世界だから
「お腹が満腹になった」
と喜ぶのであって
「お腹が空いた 良かった良かった」
と思う人はいないでしょう？
それは人間の次元なのです
人間は無茶苦茶ですけど
いろんな次元のことは
味わってはいますけど
天界というのは
そういう楽しみとか
快楽というものを食にしているのです
だから 皆様方は
天界に生まれ変わったならば
そこで遊ぶことやら
音楽を演奏したり
踊ったり 歌ったり
できるだけ
性的な行為を思う存分やったりとか
食べ物に溢れているとか
そういうイメージを
作っているかもしれませんけど
あれは楽しい 天界に行きたいと
本当は天界に行ったらそんなことを
しなかったら死ぬのです
彼らがあれで楽しんでいる訳ではなくて
必死で生きているのです
遊ばなければ死ぬ
音楽の波動で生きている神々は
きちんと時間にその音楽の
波動を食べなかったら
死んでしまうのです
だから我々は楽しくなるために
演奏を聴いたりするのですが
向こうの場合は これは
生死の問題です
死ぬか生きるか
行ってみて下さい 天界に
そこで更に修行なんかをしていると
ものすごく上の次元が
いろいろあるのです
人間と神々はいろんな関わりが
なぜあるかというと
我々を食べ物にしている
神々がいるのです
いわゆる生命は 例えば人間が
人間だけではないのだけれど
それぞれの次元の生命が
楽しく食べて子どもを作って
平和でとても良かった 良かった
という気持ちで生きているのだと
満足感で その満足感というこころの
エネルギーの波動を食にしている
そういう生命体が
我々にいくらか満足感を与えて
くれるようなことをする
そんなに助けてはくれませんけど
かなりわがままです
ただ満足感で生きている人から
そういうエネルギーを
受け取るだけであって
他の人は助けてあげません
そこはまた決まっているのです
例えば満足感のエネルギーを
食べている次元がいて
その次元がいっぱいこういうものを
食べたいと思ったら
人類みんな満足にしてしまえば
良いでしょう？
それはできないのです
餌があると食べる
なかったら死ぬということは
我々と同じなのです
だから神々を頼ったとしても
それほど役に立ちません
だいたい「幸福な奴らは
いつでも幸福ではないか」と
怒って言う場合があるでしょう？
それはそうなのです
かなり幸福な 何をしても
成功する人々のところには
それを食にしている生命が
付いているのです
だから何をやっても成功する
恨んでもしょうがないのです
皆様方はかなり怠けて
掃除もロクにしないで
子どもともけんかをする
旦那さんがうちに来るとすぐに
けんかを売ってしまうとか
そういう環境を作ったら
どんどんその環境が
膨張して大きくなってしまうのです
我々が出すエネルギーを
餌にしている生命がいるのだから
だから
大変です
ですから「いつでも明るくいて下さい」
というのはそういう訳なのです
冗談でも「怒るな」と
怒ってしまったら
どんな霊がつくか分からないという
怒りの霊がついてしまったら
ずっと怒らなくてはいけないのです
低次元のものがついてしまったら
上座部仏教はそういう話はしません
私はしているのだけど
知ってはいるのだけど
みんな追っ払ってしまうのです
自分のこころの力で生きていようと
頑張ってしまうのです
自分をともし火にして
自分を島にして
頼るなと 他人に頼るなと
大変危険です それは
そこで
もっと高い次元のことをもっと言うと
例えば 瞑想でもして
こころの汚れを全部無くして
欲がない喜びを味わう
人がいるのです
皆様の中に瞑想の経験がある方々が
いらっしゃいますから
たまにでもヴィパッサナー瞑想をして
気持ち良いと感じたことはある
と思います
それは 何もしないで
好きな音楽も聴かないで
好きな食べ物も食べないで
好きな遊びもしないで
ただ座って自分の呼吸だけ見ていると
それで何とか質の違う
楽な感じ
楽しみの感じ
ああ楽だな リラックスだなと
と感じる場合があるのです
それは貪（むさぼ）りから
離れた幸福と言うのです
質が違う
音楽を聴いて楽しいという感じと
何も音を聞かないで落ち着いている
楽しみは違うでしょう？どうしても
何も音を聞かないで
完全たる静けさを楽しむと
そうするとその質が違う
そういう欲から離れた
楽しみを味わうと
そういう次元もあるのです
それはかなり高度な次元で
そこに生まれたら
寿命はとても長いのです
なぜ長いかというと
そこら辺の生命体の食べ物は
「何もしないこと」なのです
音楽を聴こう
異性と遊ぼうとか
そういうことではなくて
そういうものから離れましょうと
清らかなこころでいようと
だから生まれたら
清らかなこころですから
それをそのまま放っておけば
こころは清らかだから
だからそれはそのまま食になる
栄養になってしまうのです
ですから ずっとこの
宇宙は一回壊されるまで
二回壊されるまでとか
寿命は行っているのです
億単位で
兆 万単位で数えなくてはいけない
彼らの寿命の長さが
それぐらい長い時間いられる
いて 死ぬ
最後に
だからずっとこの清らかなこころは
ずっとあって
どんどん力が弱くなりますから
（弱く）なって やっぱり
刺激が欲しいとなるのです
音楽 何か音でも聞いた方が良いと
なってしまったら「バイバイ」と
その生命から
人間は死ぬ時はやっぱり
１か月とか３か月間位かかります
死が近づいたら
だいたい１年ぐらいで気づくのです
人間の頭が悪いというのは
それははっきり気づかないのです
気づいたとしても
ということは 私は前に質問したでしょう？
来世（に転生）する原因は
分かっているでしょうと
本当は分かっているのです
気付いていない
例えば 「死にたくない」という
衝動でしょう？
「死にたくない」という
衝動は知っているのだから
それは来世（に転生）する
衝動なのです
それで
死ぬ時まで１年ぐらいに
なってくると
こころで分かるのです 自分が
そろそろ寿命 人生は終わりと
終わりだと分かるのだけど
それをどういう風に
すぐ分かるかというと
みんな何か落ち着きが消えてしまう
自分の面倒
もうおばあちゃん
おじいちゃんだから
もうそれほど自由もないし
面倒を見てくれる人々に
当たってしまう
ひどくわがままを言う
例えば おむつを替えたり
いろんなことをしても
「痛いではないか」
ああだこうだとか
自分で不自由なのに
今までなかったように
ひどくわがままは言うわ
子どもに執着するわ
財産に執着するわ
すぐ腹が立つわ
あれは良くないのだけど
それはこの脳細胞で
そうなってしまうのです
脳細胞はここで置いて行きますから
このこころのエネルギーで
「もうそろそろ...
あなたバイバイしなさい」と
言っているところなのです
それでこころと体と知識は
バランスが合わないのです
本当は死にたくない
ですから もうわがままを
言っているのです
皆様のそういう風に一応
もう寿命になっている人々が
わがままをいくら言ったとしても
あまり腹が立ってはいけないのです
はっきりと私たちでも理解して
おかなくてはいけないのです
その方はもう
そろそろですと
それでその執着を捨てることを
教えてあげなくてはいけないのです
例えば 財産のことを
亡くなりつつある人がしゃべったら
いまだにそんなことを
考えているのですか？と
財産が何の役に立つのですか？と
その欲・執着を捨てる方向へ
こころを持って行かなくてはいけない
はっきりと自分が死ぬことは
出来れば言ってあげた方が
その人は良い所に生まれ変わるのです
「あと何年生きているつもりですか？」と
私だったら言います
それでもって 大変なことになった
ケースは一つもないのです
私に脅かされた人々は
ものすごく落ち着いたのだから
死ぬ時になって文句を言うわ
悪口を言うわ
みんな面倒見ている人々に
いろいろなことを言うわ
よく面倒をみていると
「おかゆを食べたい」と言うのです
それでおかゆを作ったところで
「これは食べられません」と
「パンを一枚食べたいのだ」と
そこで「これは軟らかくてトースト
していないから嫌だ」と言うのです
トーストを持って行くと（今度は）
「これは硬くて食べられません」と
「ご飯がおいしいのだ」と
そこで
面倒を見ている人は
もう大変でしょう？
その人々も本当に誤解しているのです
その人は本当におかゆを食べたがっている
と思ってしまうのです
そうではないのです
あれは死を見て体験しているのだから
もうそろそろ死ぬのだから
の混乱なのです
私だったらすぐ
テーラワーダ仏教の信者さんだったら
いとも簡単に言うのです
「あなたは何のつもりですか？」と
「あとどれぐらいいるつもりですか？」と
「周りの人々に慈しみのこころを
作るのは当然ではないか」と
言ったら 落ち着くのです
ある人がもう急に病気になって
その人かなりの年齢で
倒れてしまって
本人が「まあ死ぬだろう」と
思ってしまったのです
それでえらく混乱して
病院に行く前にいろいろ
ああだこうだとしゃべっているのです
それで「鍵は？」と
鍵のこと
僕は頭に来て
「死ぬ時は鍵を持っていく
つもりですか？」と
「いい加減 車に乗りましょう」と
それで落ち着いたのです
いきなり 瞬間に
「鍵を持っていくつもりですか？」と
病気は治りましたけど 結局
たとえ衰弱していても治ります
癌になったらとても
有り難いのです 人が
だから 「いつ死ぬのか」と
もう決まっているのだから
だから 癌は告知するべきです
例えば 日本みたいな社会で
人の死を言わないということは
どれほど
人間のレベルより以下に
我々は生きているかということなのです
そういう訳も分からない話は
いっぱい言いましたけど
生まれて一日で死ぬ...
生命もいて
生まれてから
何兆年でも
宇宙が一つ出来上がって
また消えてまた出来上がるとか
そこまで寿命が長い生命もいるのです
我々は微生物などを見ていると
生まれてその場で 見ている場で
死んでしまうのです
それでもその生命はちゃんとした
寿命を果たしているのです
ちゃんと生まれて大人になって
自分の仕事をして
子孫を残して死んでいるのです
だからその微生物から聞けば
きちんと長生きしました
ということになるのです
そういうことであんまり
この時間というのは
そんな大変な複雑なものである
ということも理解して下さい
とにかく時間になりましたので
質問はするどころではないと
思いますけど
余りにも頭がこんがらがってしまって
来世の本当の姿は
二部で言ったようなことで
なかなか人間には理解しにくい
ものなのです
本当の所はそういうことなのです
皆様には信じるしか 何も
他の疑問にすることは
できないと思います
「なぜ地獄には苦しみがありますか？」
とか
それはその人は勝手に
苦しんでいるのだから
それは食にしているからなのです
分からない場合は
「なぜ人は戦争に行くのですか？」と
なぜ兵隊さんが堂々とテロとか
「あなたは死ぬでしょう？」と
「それでも行きます」と
「行ってテロをやります」と
あれはその人の生きがいなのです
この異次元の世界の場合は
それは食そのものなのです
人間もご飯だけ食べている訳
ではないのです
人間の食はご飯でしょう？
そうだと思っていますけど
それは嘘です
例えば 人を
箱に入れてしまって
管から栄養だけあげて
何も音を聞こえないようにする
目も閉じておく
鼻にも香りが入らないようにする
身体には麻酔を打っておく
何も感じないように
身体に麻酔を打って
鼻にも何も入らないようにして
口にも何も入れないようにして
目を閉ざして
耳に音が入らないようにして
管で栄養だけ与える
ちゃんと酸素も与えてあげる
その人は生きていられると
思いますか？
せいぜい１か月間は
（生きて）いるかもしれません
死ぬのです
身体を麻痺させているのだから
身体から刺激がないでしょう？
それで刺激がないと
神経はどうなるのですか？
神経細胞は死ぬ
音が耳に入らないと
耳が聞こえなくなる
身体を動かさないと
身体の筋肉は全部
痩せて痩せて
消えて行ってしまう
それで心臓発作を起こして死ぬ
ですから 生きるために
我々はただご飯だけを食べている
訳ではないのです
いろんな刺激を食べているのです
それも食なのです
美しいものを見るわ
なぜ皆様は 自分の家はいっぱい
デザインをしていますか
インテリアをやっていますか
そうすると気持ち良いのです
元気になるのです
なぜ音楽を聴いているのですか
音楽がなければ 無茶苦茶かなり
大きな声でしゃべっているでしょう
うるさくて もう
私は本当にこういう風に話す時だけ
皆に聞こえるように話しますけど
普通 私の声はそばにいる人
にしか聞こえない
全然大きな声は出しませんけど
でも二百人 四百人でも集めて
こういう機械がない場合は
口でしゃべります 聞こえるように
それはそれで
皆様は違うのです
音楽でもない場合は
キャーキャーと
ものすごいカラスみたいに
良くしゃべるのです
何ですか 上野の何とか道路の
物を売っているのです
何でしたか あの道路は
御徒町の方で
（※アメ横か）
そんな道路でかなり大きな声で
しゃべるではないですか
あれがなかったらかなり
落ち込んでしまうのです
栄養がなくて
あれは栄養なのです
食なのです
なぜ本なんか読んだりしているのですか
あれは自分の食べ物なのです
そこで人間は本当に雑食なのです
異次元の人々と違って
もともと猿なのですけど
野菜や芋だけを食べていれば良いのに
肉も食べるし 魚も食べるし
ご飯も食べるし
いろんなものを食べてしまうでしょう？
蛇も食べてしまうし
それはそれで物質だから
またいろんな刺激も食べているのです
例えば 歳をとってくると
マッサージしてもらうでしょう？
それで健康を保つ 元気になる
そういうことなのです
あれは食になるのです
そこで僕は今言いたがっているのは
プロレスリングをやらせて
みんなとても楽しがって
いるのではないか
もう拍手しながら
人にボクシングさせて
かなり気持ち良くなってしまうのです
タイとかインドネシアとか
そういう国々で
ニワトリを闘わせたりするし
中国人が小さな魚もお互いに闘わせて
それでお金かけて
一匹が必ず死ぬのです
それでも闘わせたりして
だから人の死ぬこと
生命の恐怖
怒り 苦しみ
それも食にしている
人間がいるのだから
だから雑食は良くないのです
食べるのだったら 上等なものを
食べなくてはいけないのです
だからそういう人々はやっぱり
仏教では禁じられているのです
動物を闘わせること
人を闘わせること それを見ること
それにお金をかけること
それらは禁じられているのです
僕は意味が分かります
そんなことをしてしまったら
低次元の生命のエネルギーと
似ています
波動が合いますから
死ぬ時もそこに行ってしまいます
ですから皆様は雑食で良いのだけど
選んでください 自分の食べ物を
音楽を聴くならば それなりの
頭も良くなる こころも安らかになる
意味のある立派な音楽を聴いて下さい
下らない音楽を聴かないで
お互いに話し合って
それを栄養にしているならば
意味のあることをしゃべって下さい
大事なことを美しい言葉で
相手のこころを痛める
言葉を使わないで
人間らしく そうすると
良い食をとる人間になるし
それによって
来世も良い所へ行きます
そういうことで
今日の話は終了致します
どうもありがとうございます